[Music]
howdy folks time for matinee 75 yeah now
we did not get to the movie theater this
week now coronavirus man no not because
of coronavirus because nothing new
started that's why let me let me we've
seen everything that we've seen
everything that other than Brahms but I
don't really care about things I've been
sick for a couple weeks I've got cough
drops my mouth she got excuse me cuz you
know my sinuses and yes I got that Kovac
she doesn't believe me but you don't
have got I got I got it well because if
you had Kovac I would have it too
because you've had the [ __ ] for like let
me [ __ ] fantasize why would you want
to fantasize about having a disease it
makes it more exciting
okay like I'm a part of something he's
he's still waiting for the zombie
apocalypse waiting ready for that I've
been preparing for zombie apocalypse
some people just want the world whatever
I'm gonna be proven to be a genius when
these days you're gonna say okay you say
damn Tom you were right you were right
that'll be the day
yeah so yes I'm just [ __ ] with you
so we didn't go to the movie theater and
like I said not because I can ruin a
virus but because nothing really new
started yeah well you did that not right
but that's not why so we saw some [ __ ]
in our very own home one of them was on
Netflix one of them was on shudder and
one of them we bought on blu-ray
yeah yeah color out of space yeah talk
about that you don't have that one go
ahead and buy it yeah so the first one
we're gonna talk about is a new one that
came out on Netflix called the girl on
the third floor now this was the I
believe directorial debut of a guy named
Travis Stevens now the main guy who was
in this I didn't realize it when I was
watching his name is CM Punk and he's
actually an MMA fighter so I believe
this is his first acting role now he is
very I couldn't decide while I was
watching the movie I guess like the more
I thought about it the more I was like
okay I see where where he was going with
that
um while I was watching the movie I
couldn't decide I'm like he's either
like a really bad actor or he's or this
is like a black comedy now I'm leaning
more toward black comedy because he
comes off very much like Bruce Campbell
and if they ever make a biopic of Bruce
Campbell this dude should definitely why
mean Bruce Campbell can still play Bruce
Campbell in a biopic of Bruce Campbell
but if somehow he wasn't available
this guy could totally do it because he
has the same facial expressions the same
type of voice the same everything yet in
mannerism my impression was is that the
tone they were going for was kind of
like evil Ted it was it was Evil Dead
meets Cronenberg yeah cuz there was like
some kind of weird [ __ ] going on with
the house like the house bleeding and
stuff yeah so he can tell you no he's
not really taking it seriously and
you're not really taking it seriously
but they're just they're entertaining
you and that's kind of the old school
way we used to watch horror movies I
loved Evil Dead yeah I didn't take it
seriously even though scared me yeah
yeah me it was weird kiss you know but
then you kind of you'd laugh it off oh
no I mean this movie girl on the third
floor it's not as it's not as zany as
Evil Dead like don't don't get me wrong
but it's it's kind of in that same
spirit it's a very you know Sam Raimi
type of yes spirit I guess even though I
don't know if I'd overtly call it a
black comedy but it does have some like
some comedic you know like some dry
comedic elements to it so basically the
setup is that um this guy played by CM
Punk that's not his real name obviously
but that's like his MMA fighter name so
he plays this guy named Don now I
suppose I think he had been a lawyer um
in Chicago and he somehow [ __ ] up like
he he like [ __ ] his clients out of a
lot of money or something like like he
got in trouble
and um he is also a [ __ ] up in other
ways like he was either recovering
alcoholic it's like he cheated on his
wife and all this other kind of crap so
he's kind of like they buy this house
kind of out in the country around the
suburbs rather and he's gonna renovate
it because his wife is pregnant and he's
like okay we're gonna start all over I'm
gonna stop drinkin I'm gonna stop
whoring around and you know I'm gonna
get another job and I'm
gonna fix this house up and everything
will be perfect so he has gone to this
house and he's gonna fix it up all by
himself with no help from anybody except
his little dog Cooper and that's how
he's somehow gonna like heal his
relationship I guess or kind of get his
[ __ ] back together but that's not how it
works out because turns out this house
is kind of haunted but in a weird sort
of way it's like it kind of all starts
where he's in the house and this girl
turns up who says that she's the
neighbor and she basically just turns up
in the backyard and she was like oh I
live around here and this house has
always been abandoned so I was just kind
of hung out and he's like okay let's
[ __ ]
pretty much like immediately he's trying
to be better but he's already soon as
he's at the house by himself he starts
drinking again he started screwing
around again but it turns out that this
girl you know it's a tribe because I was
saying dude it's a trap well clearly
yeah it's like soon as I saw her I go no
yeah
I mean some women don't do that but wait
some beautiful random woman turns up in
your backyard and it's like oh yeah I'll
just hang out and she's basically just
throwing herself at him and he's like
some kind of spy she's a cop and they're
investigating you or you know or she's
trying to steal from you it's not normal
that's what I mean but he falls for it
like a nomad well that's kind of the
whole point of his character he is a
sympathetic character but he's also a
[ __ ] and that becomes abundantly clear
the interesting thing about this so like
I said as it goes on like the house just
starts doing weirder and weirder [ __ ]
like all of the um like the outlets
start like oozing various fluids
sometimes he's knocking holes in the
walls like to tear a wall there or
something it looks like pulsating organs
or like blood or something like that
back so the house is kind of like alive
now he befriends this woman who's like a
pastor at the church like across the
Street and she tells him or he finds out
some that the house used to be like a
brothel like an illegal brothel the
interesting thing about this movie is
that yes you could say it's like a
standard haunted house movie but it's
not like a haunted house movie in the
sense that you know how most haunted
house movies are like oh something bad
happened there in the past and it's like
still hanging around this one almost
kind of has yes it has that aspect but
apparently everybody that lives in the
house don't experience the haunting it
was because him being a [ __ ] in the
present is almost kind of like waking it
up you know what I mean so it's kind of
like it's a little bit like The Shining
in that way where it's like you know
he's kind of like you know his character
is weak and he so he's vulnerable so the
house is kind of like coming back to
life like to take advantage yeah of his
character weakness a family in a way
that's also kind of like evil dead it is
kind of one after the cabin and being in
the cabin on you know unlock some stuff
from the Necronomicon you know yeah just
trying to come up with something to show
you it scary movie yeah and I the thing
that I liked about this one is that it
had like a really interesting like a
interesting premise it also had like a
like a bit of surrealism like going on
into to which I thought was kind of cool
I really liked the the aspect of like
the house almost like an organism you
know we're I mean literally where
there's like it seemed like there was
organs and [ __ ] like that behind them
well pretty good special effect it did
actually and I don't think this movie
was all that expensive um and as I said
this guy's this apparently this is his
first movie the house that they used
that's a real house and I guess that he
had bought that house like to use as the
headquarters for his production company
and it was being renovated and he's like
don't finish renovating it because we're
gonna make this movie in here because
that was part of the plot was that this
house was being renovated so a lot of
good horror franchise just kind of
started it off that way you know yeah
the guy who did fantastic
ya know Don Kaas really yeah I just kind
of make his own movies just made a bunch
out well I feel like horror I mean I
guess all genres but horror
particular since that's what I'm most
familiar with it does seem to be better
when it's just the vision of one person
or a small group of people yeah it
doesn't work out when it's committee
when you do horror by committee it
doesn't work out so good then you just
kind of get these bland
jumps scary type crap that's just
forgettable you know kind of best when
they're mid to low budget works of from
the heart really yeah really like the
genre or I really love the genre and
want to do something with it
yes I don't leave especially if you're
starring in it kind of deal yeah those
are actually getting written a lot
better I think it's because the guy
who's producing it directing it and
starring in it and involved in it he's
kind of making a manifestation of his
his dreams and his ego yeah so it turns
out to be it's better because he cares
yeah yeah well everything is always
better if it's just like a small group
of people they really really want to do
this and this is their vision then if
it's just a bunch of faceless people
going well we need to check these boxes
off to make X amount of money back you
know it's aw yeah I wanna ghosts put a
ghost in there no you want to wear what
put away the kids will love it yeah well
even though I mean I guess that models
successful too because like that people
do go see those but like that director
who commented on the review that we did
this was a couple years back the one
about the crazy-ass crack remember that
we're doing the weird drugs and seen the
monsters that was a long time ago that
was a good movie what is that one again
I can't remember which one you're
talking about it was it cracking they
were doing yeah they were doing that
crazy crack and seeing aliens crazy crap
oh um
welcome to Willits welcome to it wasn't
crack it was some it was math or myth
some kind of weird weed or something
like some kind of hybrid yeah it was
putting in contact with evil aliens
women um or were they the undead it's
I'd like to see it again I like that
movie no I don't think they're actually
I don't even remember if there were any
aliens they thought they were but it
didn't matter cuz you're seeing them
yeah you're seeing them as I watch the
movie so you know so yeah so this is on
Netflix like I said it seems like I
don't think
got a theatrical release it did play at
a whole bunch of film festivals and seem
to have gotten really a positive reviews
like I said it's not you know the best
movie I ever saw like but it has like a
really cool like vision to it so I'm
really interested to see what this
director does next because this was a
very interesting movie and I suggest
that you
okay second movie we saw this week I've
been looking forward to this one for a
really long time HP Lovecraft's color
out of space with a Nicholas Cage
excellent movie we ordered it on blu-ray
pre-ordered it and it showed up in good
condition has slipcover on it wasn't
steelbook but didn't really have to be
excellent movie same same basic kind of
team that did Mandy wasn't it it was the
same production team which is Spectre
vision that's like a production company
that that actor Elijah Wood founded as
far as I know like him and a couple
other people so yeah this isn't it's a
work of greatness kind of like Mandy
it's just a difference its Lovecraft
it's not quite as crazy and II like it
has like a more grounded story to it I
guess but it's still really cool I
thought it farm about this family that's
on this farm they actually moved there
from the city it was like an ancestral
farm and meteor lands in the backyard
and it's some kind of weird color it's
some kind of alien thing gets in the
damn ground water starts affecting all
the animals and bugs drives them crazy
does mutate some it's alien whatever it
is and it's and it's alive I know is it
one of them or is it like a collective
tart tale I don't think there's any way
I mean this is kind of one of those I
mean obviously Lovecraft is very very
difficult to adapt to film just because
so much of his stuff is like unnameable
and undescribable and all this other
stuff so I don't really know if you know
is there a distinction because it's so
alien and we wouldn't understand it is
there even like a distinction between an
individual alien and are like a
collective of aliens or is it just like
a vast intelligence that off the top the
movie kind of reminded me of Prince of
Darkness but a prince of but a good one
you mix kind of like Prince of Darkness
in with the thing
carpenter too cause this has some very
thing and yeah but econo in some ways
kind of feels a little bit like Mandy
because you got Nicolas Cage just being
crazy as [ __ ] through the whole thing
dude he does he's just [ __ ] he's a
national treasure and I know I know what
I know
and all kinds of cool [ __ ] happens in it
good special effects shot real well good
script and there's gonna be more of them
dude who made it is talking about doing
a dumb witch [ __ ] and that's gonna be
[ __ ] awesome he wants to do a trilogy
uh man I hope he does in the mountains
of madness too
yeah I mean I don't know if Guillermo
del Toro still has the rights to do that
you know that's been what although it's
all in public domain I guess anybody
could make their yeah that's been in
like I don't want to see that though but
yeah so Richard Stanley who wrote and
directed this he did the adaptation he's
been a big Lovecraft fan forever now
Richard Stanley he did hardware and he
did the island of dr. Moreau where he
very famously was fired from it that was
back in 1996 I actually like them now
they made a whole documentary about that
called lost souls which used to be on
shudder but I didn't get a chance to
watch it and then when I checked
yesterday it wasn't there anymore but so
this guy he's kind of like a mad genius
so it's like so he hasn't directed a
movie since 1996 yeah in the in the
bonus features he's seen I reclaim my
director's chair yeah he's just crazy
[ __ ] God dude with long black hair and
a little good clothes living out in
[ __ ] ink and some ancient part in
France something damn yeah i reclaim my
director's chair oh dude yeah and
apparently um him and his mom like he
said his mom used to read HP Lovecraft
stories to him when he was a kid and
then he said that you know when his mom
got cancer later on that he would read
the stories to her like when she was
convalescing and the reason that Jolie
Richardson's character in color out of
space is recovering from a mastectomy
like from breast cancer and the reason
that he put that in there was like as an
homage to his mom because his mom was
the one that kind of instilled the love
of Lovecraft
into him when he was little so he's
gonna want to do this and like I said he
he has talked about wanting to do the
Dunwich horror next and he wants to do
another movie after that too but I'm not
sure which one a lot of cool [ __ ] down
which or it is yeah I would
of the scene at dawn by this director I
hope Nicolas Cage is in it I hope
Nicolas Cage's and all of them yeah
those kids should be in all movies raka
said that Nicolas Cage gave him gave him
a belief in American Hollywood actress
again so yeah rekindled his belief that
you could have an actor that really
cared about what they were doing we're
tenth were touted and were [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] Nic Cage is [ __ ] crazy
he's been waitin a good yeah he in a fun
way revs himself up and you could see
some behind the scenes shots where he
[ __ ] revving himself up and to
insanity to do these to do this to do
these performances and he it's like
Mandy he's [ __ ] Mandy not ya pardon
[ __ ] Mandy we actually we've actually
watched Mandy again like I don't we
watch this one so people I compare those
two movies these two movies can stand
side by side Mandy though is kind of
like uh the way it's shot and the tone
is kind of like a Frank Frazetta
painting on acid yeah happening in the
early 80s that's what it's like her late
70s stuff bleeding on into it and
everything it's imagine it's like
something out of damn heavy metal
magazine ever had ya know comic book
like that kinda this one is just as good
but the tone is a lot different you're
dealing with sci-fi sci-fi horror this
one has a lot more humor in it yeah yeah
and not all of it comes from Nicolas
Cage because somewhat like some of the
kids um you know the three kids that are
in it which I thought was funny they
named the daughter Lavinia which is a
character from the Dunwich horror
lavinia whateley yeah so uh so he's kind
of like trying to get in on that you
know ahead of time but there's a you
know there's a lot more like with the
Sun being kind of like you know a stoner
and then like the daughter being like a
Wiccan and then Nicolas Cage wanting to
move this family out to this farm I
guess because you know his wife has had
cancer and they're trying to like move
away from the city and stuff and he has
decided that he's gonna like grow
vegetables and also raise alpacas
because they're the animal of the future
but he thought people
alpacas I'm sure people eat alpacas if
there's nothing else around no but I
feel like they usually milk alpacas or
ride them now you make sweater or make
sweaters out of them they're pack
animals right it's like making wool yeah
it's a pack animal yeah you can get wool
awesome but the funny thing about it I
was like I was watching a review of this
but like on some other channel and
somebody in the comments said that I
never knew that I needed to see Nicholas
Cage milking an alpaca yeah now that I'm
half the movies got real good special
effects
there's mutated insect looking things
some of its practical effects some of
its CG the color from outer space which
you have to see it to understand it it
was like some kind of weird it was a
meteor first but then somehow it
channeled down a lightning bolts and
there was also kind of like this weird
magenta color that came down with it
some kind of life force life energy yeah
kind of like leeches into the ground and
into the water and stuff like that
because you can hear like Tommy Chong
who is in this as like kind of like a
STONER character named IRA who lives on
there like on this little thing on their
property and he's kind of like listening
to them so you can hear like kind of
these weird like alien voices like under
the ground and stuff yeah and it's
leaching into things and drawing the
life out of stuff and trying to
transform the [ __ ] trying to
transform the the at least this plate
that part of Earth into into wherever it
came from there's some kind of an extra
dimensional element it's not clearly
defined and that's just the way it isn't
but that's the way it is in the story I
mean in this very obviously they had to
you know because the story is quite
short but they so in the story like you
know the the surveyor guy is coming
there and talking to this dude who lives
on the property who's kind of like the
Ezra character that in the movie and
he's telling about what happened to the
Gardner family like many years ago this
one it's you know the the timeline is
very truncated so because it happens
over like a pretty short period of time
they move to this farm the you know the
asteroid or the meteor lands and then
everything starts to happen like really
quickly like they start all star
going insane like the tomatoes come up
like all deformed like the alpacas go
apeshit and like you know something like
stuff happens
something like stuff happens to some
members of the family as well
and everything is kind of like bathed in
this and like the little kid I think is
a he's actually played by the little kid
that was in haunting a pill house now
that's the kid with the big glasses and
he starts like saying there's a man down
in the well like somebody down the
whales like talking to Souls and
mysterious [ __ ] starts to happen yeah
and um
at first I think he thinks the little
kid at least thinks the color is like
really beautiful like they all seem to
think it's like cuz it is super cool
looking when it comes into it it's like
this pink and purple yeah don't want to
spoil this movie they know else there
it's streaming now they're streaming it
off of youtube yeah you could probably
find it in other places I'd recommend it
on blu-ray if you're if you liked Mandy
if you're a fan of Mandy you will love
this movie yeah it's not like I said you
liked it Lovecraft movies this is one of
the best if not the best Lovecraft ad up
there was from beyond the reanimate er
series the one with the Geoffrey columns
type yes movies you know me they're
they're like that it's actually better
than those and it's a lot more the
quality's higher it looks a lot better
it it really seems I mean it's probably
closer to the original story yeah I mean
it is changed some they do have like a
surveyor character that comes there and
they are building a hydroelectric dam
which I think in the original story they
were gonna flood the [ __ ] and like make
a reservoir out of it you know implying
that the water was going to be poisoned
so everybody that drank out of it was
gonna you know what I mean you know they
didn't go so they do go into that but
they're basically in the story it's the
surveyor talking to the guy that lived
on the property about the [ __ ] that
happened to the family like a long time
ago whereas in the movie it's brought to
the present day like you're seeing
what's happening to the Gardner family
this is definitely as good as daga yeah
and this is a very good one yeah this is
obviously a lot more sci-fi oriented
than that it's
like I've seen some people compare it to
like annihilation but it's in visually
at least the same cinematographer that
did this also did I am mother which we
reviewed a while back that was good that
was a really good sci-fi movie too
that's on still on Netflix yeah it's the
subject matter that's different you're
not dealing with sea gods or you know
Cthulhu or anything like that you're
dealing with some kind of alien force
and that's really what makes the story
different from Dagon it's a different
topic yeah but because it's a different
it's a different creature the situation
is different but it's just it to me I
liked it as much as daga I did too it's
a totally different kind of thing even
though it's both love crafty and
obviously but like I said it's more
cosmic than yeah kind of like remember
in Creepshow the one the one where the
guys getting eaten it eaten by the moss
yeah what was the name of that Lonesome
death of Jordy Verrill yeah that's a
very short story this is kind of like a
very high-end version of that and I
think Stephen King because color out of
space was Stephen King's as far as I can
remember was his favorite Lovecraft
story so I think that when he wrote
lonesome death of the surety Barrel I
think that he was that that was like his
riff on it okay yeah because because
I've heard like in Danse Macabre you
talked about that story quite a bit
right maybe she liked it
so yeah so definitely were that inspired
that one yeah yeah yeah and you can see
it like with the alien weed and
everything like that and coming from the
meteor because when when we were
watching color out of space in the
meteor landed the first I had to
restrain myself from saying meteor [ __ ]
because I know that that's like where
that inspired from but yes so definitely
definitely this seems to be getting it
got like a very brief theatrical release
because I know that um some of the
channels like horror channels I watched
they had seen it in the theater I think
it only played in like 80 theaters in
the US and I think it played in a few in
the UK as well because I saw some
British reviewers that had seen it in
the theatre Hollywood politics Hollywood
kept it out they didn't want to compete
with their movies how much you want a
bet I feel like a lot of movies don't
get as wide theatrical I think it's just
because they don't think it's gonna make
any model believe so which is dumb
because this movie and Mandy I think
would have done better at the box office
than a lot of the [ __ ] shitty or
we've been seeing lately yeah probably
yeah that's the sad thing is like it I
think it has to do with who makes them
and who their friends are and what how
deep they are on the scene and these are
kind of independent films and they don't
want them in there competing with the
money they don't that's what I'm
thinking yeah that's just what I'm
thinking I think it's business I think
partly yeah we're gonna Hollywood
businesses to keep competitors out of
your damn theaters you gotta be I would
do it so they must be doing it yeah but
like I said this did get a limited
theatrical release you know not just not
just at festivals and stuff it actually
did play in some theaters in some bigger
cities in this country and maybe in
other places in Europe to I'm not sure
but I know that it played in some
theaters in the UK this what a kicked
ass in the theatres of it I feel like a
lot and I kind of wish that I'd got to
see it on the big screen cuz I'm sure it
looked amazing this have been promoted
rights and sent into the theaters it
would have done well sewed of Mandy
Mandy would have done real [ __ ] well
I would also love to see they imagined
you saw Mandy in Dolby yeah Dolby
Theatre somebody you know what here in
Orlando we have like a like in little
indie theatre full that's yeah it's been
there like forever called the Enzian I
wondered would they ever do they should
do a Nicholas Cage double feature they
should do this and Mandy yeah I would be
first in line for that [ __ ] oh we
watched him back to back and we did yes
because I really would really love to
see them on the big screen these
definitely need to be seen on the big
screen now if he comes out with horror
and it's in the same vein as those same
level of quality which I'm pretty sure
it will be if it's got Nicolas Cage in
it I'll hope of a Nicolas Cage [ __ ]
dumb witch [ __ ] will be knocked out of
the park yeah I'm so I'm excited I'm
excited too I hope I really do hope that
he can get like stories honestly I don't
know how much this cost to make I
couldn't really find like a good figure
of how much this cost to make I'm she
was very low-budget I'm sure but it
doesn't look like it at all through most
of the Dunwich horror books the monsters
are kind of invisible they're mad
visible at the very end so you could
fight him so we'll see yeah we'll see
how it goes I'm like I said I'm pulling
for you Richard Stanley seriously yeah
do a Kickstarter or something get some
more life [ __ ] going yeah you need we
will watch it fast yeah
get a Kickstarter raise the money make
the [ __ ] movie man yeah we're there
you know for their certain amount of
money like I'd give you know I'd give
you the money for for blu-ray upfront
for the for a pre-sale and that's where
the money could come from yeah cuz we
bought this on presale yeah about 20
bucks I think I was twenty bucks yeah
yeah we ordered it like before I came in
yeah 25th yeah I would hook up with
Ethan Van Sciver because they've been
doing that they did the expandables the
extended expendable excuse me
yeah The Expendables go to hell
comic-book they raised like a hundred
thousand dollars just in a few weeks
yeah and especially Stallone was
involved in that so there's got to be
something going on kind of like kind of
like with what that skiver is doing
because you know I mean trying to bring
good movies and comics back you know
independent stuff well like I said it's
kind of like it's a lot kind of
restrictive man well it's a lot better
nowadays because look how one it's a lot
cheaper to make movies and two there's
so many more like options you don't like
have to go the big studio route you
don't even have to go to like even back
in the 70s you got to go to like grind
house theaters and stuff like that you
don't have to do that anymore you can
just go straight to [ __ ] yeah VOD
there's all kind of different like
options that you go straight to your
fans they'll [ __ ] pay you yeah
because the big crowdsourcing right yeah
the old-fashioned Studio way man you
know it's too corrupt
let's be honest man well and they you
know they want to see a return on their
you know investment and a lot of times
they kind of want to make these big
tentpole type movies for a hundred
million dollars which means that now you
have to make 300 million for that movie
named breakeven and a lot of those
movies are okay but they're not really
all that great well they have huge
overheads and they have [ __ ] mansions
and pools to pay to pay for and you know
I mean they have to cover the losses
that they made with the other movies
that [ __ ] bombed
yeah they're it's too expensive why do
that when you can just make the movie
you want to make you have to worry about
paying off the ship to failed yeah and
paying off [ __ ] every Tom Dick and
Harry you do but you know that's why I
was so happy that Universal actually
made [ __ ] The Invisible Man
for seven million dollars yeah and it
was looking great good movie I said see
you don't need to [ __ ] and it made
don't need to make a mummy movie for 200
million dollars a time though he said we
don't want to see that [ __ ] yeah and and
make a good movie for seven million yeah
and it made three times its money back
within a few days yeah yeah yeah cuz
it's a good [ __ ] movie less is more
nowadays you don't need all that [ __ ]
that's what I mean with I mean CG we've
seen it yeah it's like oh yeah you can
do everything we see her yeah gripped
though it's a crutch great script
raw sub subject matter that's true to
the original source material great
actors tell a good [ __ ] story that's
all it takes
yeah he doesn't have that you don't need
a bunch of money a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
practical facts you know it's good but
you don't need to you need to spend
[ __ ] millions and millions of dollars
on CG you don't know I mean the
colorado-based had a little bit of CG
and it was just enough but it was it
wasn't like overbearing it was just kind
of like a little bit like an insect or
something like that
it had a lot of snow and it had a lot of
practical effect as well like a lot of
the kind of creature effects and so your
practical effects enhanced by some CG
right the way really that's what you
should know the thing 2012 you know like
this young remake it was better-looking
than that if you asked me that's the
thing remake should have looked yeah I
think they beat the thing remake because
some of the CG and the think thing
remake didn't look and it was good for a
day but didn't really look right like I
said I didn't want to do impractical
when they [ __ ] that up the studio didn't
want I mean practical effects always
look better and practical effects if you
if you must use CGI just like to enhance
the practical yes it is minimal it's a
mixture minimal yeah don't make a whole
[ __ ] creature at a CGI though it
still never looks right and doesn't look
like I have it doesn't even know any it
doesn't look like it has any weight but
everything that they showed in this
movie was spot off yeah let me show us
all and like I said I'm sure it didn't
have a huge budget I don't know what the
bunny did it wasn't like a monster of a
monster a minute type movie it showed
you just enough yeah it wasn't too much
I liked it I did too I'm so it's
visually amazing it was just like a
really fun story it's a really good
adaptation a very close out updation of
the story that was modernized obviously
but yeah once we're gonna see it again
yeah I definitely want to watch it again
but yeah this is one that you should
definitely buy on blu-ray
yeah um you know support the [ __ ] maybe
he'll make more Lovecraft movies if
we're lucky and hopefully Nicolas Cage
will be in there acting like a crazy
person
yeah and milking alpacas
okay third movie we saw this week just
dropped on shudder now the weird thing
from what I could determine when I was
researching this movie I think this
movie was actually made in 2017 but it
didn't get a wide release on VOD until
late last year like late 2019 and
shudder just added it a few days ago and
shutter has it listed as a 2019 movie so
I said well that's fair enough that's
still kind of new and I needed a third
movie for the show so I decided to go
ahead and watch it this movie is called
replace now the guy that directed it
Norbert or Norbert Kiel I believe he's
German and this is his first he had made
like a couple of other movies in Germany
and I believe this was shot in German -
Germany - but it's in English and
probably the biggest draw this is
Barbara Crampton as ya guys she's gotta
be in her late 50s man she's still hot
man she was cute yeah she looks great in
this she plays like kind of like a mad
scientist
yeah character not a mad scientist but
like a creepy scientist you don't know
who that is she was the one that was
played in a lot of the the HP Lovecraft
movies yes Stuart Gordon yeah yeah he
was in reanimate her she was an animator
she was in from beyond and yeah she was
hot blonde yeah
and she's still acting nowadays it's
like I was really surprised to see her
and this she was in a movie called
beyond the gates she was in the latest
season of channel zero uh kind of
briefly she was in a couple of episodes
for that but yeah so she's and the you
know what's weird is like just like
probably an hour before you recorded
this show cuz I'm a follower Barbara
Crampton on Instagram and I just saw
that she just finished shooting a movie
which I guess is a horror movie called
Jacob's wife and that movie was directed
by Travis Stevens who's the same guy
that directed girl on the third floor so
I was like woo all three movies are
connected this weekend I didn't even
mean to do that
but yeah so this movie replaced it's
basically it's kind of a little
Cronenberg ian um one thing that I will
say it's like if you really like stuff
like the neon demon
the perfection or perfect or some of
these movies that have this kind of like
retro wave aesthetic like the lighting
in this and the score in this is very
like really really cool like I [ __ ]
loved the score of that a new retro way
of music in it yeah definitely there's a
there's a lot of that kind of stuff so
that whole like um kind of aesthetic is
like super cool a lot of like neon
lighting and stuff so the basic story is
about this girl and her name is Kara
Maybin and as the story goes on you
discover that she is one suffering from
memory lapses - she's also suffering
from this strange skin condition which
is kind of like it starts on her hand
and that it starts to spread it's almost
like her skin is getting like really
crusty like aging prematurely almost
kind of like eczema yeah like really
really bad yeah so as the story goes on
you kind of figure she figures out that
that the only way that she can like
restore her skin is basically like
taking other people's like cutting other
people's skin off and like sticking
around there and then it like kind of
stays in there so I really actually I
liked this movie but it took me a while
to get into it because I think what it's
weird because this movie when I was
saying that all these three movies were
linked together because this movie was
the director co-wrote it the other
writer was Richard Stanley the same guy
that directed color out of space so he
co-wrote this movie now the only thing
that I wish they had kind of started it
somewhere different because I think it
took me about 15 20 minutes to like to
catch the wave of the movie because they
started out where her character is
having memory lapses which factors into
the story later on but because you know
she's at the beginning she's talking to
this guy she takes this guy home and
then like she wakes up he's gone and
then she leaves the apartment like going
back to her house but then she's there
but then her house is that guy's house
and she can't
figure out and she keeps like hearing
people in her apartment she doesn't know
they are so it takes a while for that to
pay off so I was kind of like confused
for like what the [ __ ] is going on like
I get that she has the skin thing and
she's going to the doctor and there's
kind of all this stuff where Barbara
Crampton plays the doctor and she's kind
of like telling her yeah we need to do
this that and the other but but Kira
doesn't remember some things and so I
feel like I know that they were trying
to make it that you were just as
confused as the character like trying to
put your in put you in her shoes but I
think that I wish that they had started
a little bit yeah in a different spot
because it took me a while but once I
got into the movie I really got into it
yeah you calling it right yeah I mean if
violated that 10 15 minute rule I have
you gotta man yeah if I'm not hooked up
into the movie if I'm not into it and
within 5 10 15 minutes I'm never going
to be and that's kind of what happened I
stopped paying attention to it because
it's kind of like you know once you lose
the suspension of disbelief you no
longer can enjoy the movie once it's
kind of like that for me
if I can't get into it in that first 10
15 minutes I start to reject the movie
for some reason it's just the way my
mind works I start ignoring it so I
started looking down at my tablet and
getting lost in that and every now and
then I'd look up and the movie was
getting better but by that time I didn't
care as good as to stuff well it's just
it wasn't even I don't the beginning
wasn't slow it's just that I wasn't sure
she's going on right but then like after
about 15 or 20 minutes when all the
threads started coming together and I
was like oh okay I see like where they
were going with it and then it started
getting really good and um yeah so this
kind of very impatient intolerance if I
if I'm confused for too long like five
minutes or so I just got that [ __ ] you
well no cause like I said you know I'm
willing to and we were talking about
this earlier when we were talking about
assault on precinct 13 where I think
sometimes when you watch a movie you're
like fighting it yeah whereas I don't I
don't fight it I just watch it I mean it
takes a lot for me to turn a movie off
like I will usually you know give it a
chance to do what it's going to do
that's what's so good about our show
because you can write stories you're a
professional author
I'm just Joe Blow I'm gonna be the
average [ __ ] that's just sitting
in a theater who what guy who supposedly
bought the ticket okay there's more on
me than there are you in that theater
unfair to you so I could predict how
well Liv is gonna go because I
understand the lowest common denominator
I understand them I understand the - I
do understand it because you know I can
relate to it you know but yeah like I
said so you get too fancy with me or you
can't get - you can't get too vague you
can't get too confusing you can't be too
slow there's there's kind of like a but
the thing is is I don't like it real
shallow either like I like you know I'd
watch a Marvel movie and go yeah a big
[ __ ] deal and then forget it
instantly well I forget a lot of them
are yeah well I kind of enjoy it like
it's damn right or like a rollercoaster
ride but then the credits roll and I
can't I couldn't tell you what I saw
yeah I don't remember a lot of like I
enjoyed him at the time but they don't
like stick yeah and I know other people
aren't like that like a lot of people
really dig him and that's cool but it's
like I said I enjoy him at the time but
I don't that wasn't a case of color out
of space well yeah that kind of was over
and I remembered it yeah yeah this one
like I said even though it started out
like I said not necessarily slow but
kind of like I wasn't really sure what
was happening and then they Slyke you
know she has this neighbor that keeps
coming over that seems like really um
insistent that she keeps like coming
over to the house and stuff and I was
just like what the [ __ ] is going on with
that chick she's weird and all this
other kind of stuff but as it goes on
and all of the plot threads start to
come together and there are actually two
really big kind of plot twists in this
that I didn't really see coming that
have to do not only with the neighbor
that keeps coming over but also with her
skin condition and what it is where it
came from what Barbara Crampton is up to
so you know what I'm not gonna spoil or
anything like that but there are like
two kind of big revelations in there
that I didn't really see coming and so
if you this is kind of like the type of
movie where it gave me a little bit of a
vibe like that one we reviewed a while
back like bliss but I liked this a lot
better because it's
was a lot more story to this one where
bliss was just kind of like everyone
hanging out in clubs and drinking blood
and stuff this one actually had a story
in a progression and you know a plot
twist that came around like at the end
of the second act and stuff like that so
it had more of a narrative thrust than
bliss did the look was kind of similar
but I think the look of it reminded me
more of that weird like sci-fi one
perfect but again this one actually had
a story where his perfect sort of did
but it was just very kind of like
nebulous this one at even though this
one takes a while to go get where it's
going but once I got to the end I was
like okay I know why they did that
because they were playing with the whole
idea of her memory lapse and you find
out why she has those memory lapses like
later on and then it makes sense so this
is kind of one where I feel like
probably a second viewing would you know
I would probably appreciate it more in
the second viewing I really it's not
really gory but there are some kind of
Cronenberg II and I mean this is about a
girl who is killing people and cutting
off bits of their skin and like sticking
it on herself so if that sounds like
it's gonna gross you out then it'll
probably gross you out but it's not you
know it's not the most like graphic [ __ ]
I've ever seen you know what I mean
there is a little bit of like a key type
of for me the 1015 minute rule still
played out usually if I can't hook up in
the 10 in that first 10-15 minutes I'm
not gonna like the movie isn't the movie
to get better as it went on but I could
tell by what's going on I wouldn't
really like the movie much anyway it's
it's I would say it's a very female
movie it's mostly women they're mostly
cute they're mostly having sex with each
other which some guys might get into
that but just well in a lot of the a lot
of the theme of it too is that you know
women try like being afraid of getting
old um so that's kind of like a theme -
I also liked kind of the the ending
scene where Barbara Crampton was doing
what she was doing I really felt like
that was an homage to Dead Ringers I
could be wrong about that which is the
way they kind of shot it and like the
color scheme and stuff like that kind of
reminded me very much of that this did
have a little bit of a Cronenberg Ian
vibe to it
but kind of cross reference through
new retro wave kind of already sort of
horror I think that first 15 minutes
could be rieta today it would be better
for the general audience I'm thinking it
might be yeah cuz like I said even I was
just kind of like like I was kind of
interested but I'm like what is like
what's going on but then afterwards like
I said my logs kind of blocky
kinda yeah guys don't really talk that
way yeah I mean that kind of stuff I
wondered if it was dubbed because and
when I went like I said when I was
watching the the credits it seemed like
I I don't know if it was shot in Germany
but it was like funded German and I
believe that the director is German so
I'm wondering they talk that way in
Germany well no I mean maybe they did
like they used to do back in Italy in
the day where it's like everybody was
just like talk in their own accents and
then they would just dump everything I'm
not really sure if that's what I mean
obviously Barbara Crampton wasn't dubbed
because that was her real voice but I'm
not sure about the other actors because
apparently it's like some of the other
actors kind of sounded like they were
dubbed maybe it was just like a TR and
it was their own voices I don't know but
yeah so it's on shudder if you want to
check it out if you're like into like
kind of arty Cronenberg Ian type before
sort of filtered through an 80s new
retro wave aesthetic and if you liked
stuff like the neon demon or the
perfection or so like that this kind of
reminded me that it was in that kind of
vein so it's on shudder it's probably
streaming other places too so check it
out if you
[Music]